anytime that we think of Mona and a lair
we go back to the very beginning of
Yeller yeah the guy Mart right she needs
to see everything up she puts all the
pieces together so I think everybody
that's on her board you know it all has
to do with who's ad I've been asked to
help play this game and figure out all
the little pieces of it is there some
shady business going on maybe so will
Mona have a turn will she have a turn in
the bourdain well let's just say that
the darkness of the board game starts to
bring out a little bit of a darkness in
Mona you know like you said old habits
die hard she even said it earlier like
I'm scared to touch it you know I mean I
was an addict as well to playing with
people's lives and being involved in
being you know the puppet master and I
think you'll start to see over these
next few episodes it does it does take a
little turn in Mona oh no way I'm so
upset right now he wants to know if
Mona's gonna die
uh-huh another million-dollar question I
mean yeah that's that's always you know
who's gonna die in Rosewood people die
people come back to it I mean I've been
dead already you know Trina has have to
again go and see its finale gonna be
like that one episode where it was the
summer of answers where we had the big
reveal in the beginning and then the
rest of the episode is filling in the
piece in the pieces um I don't know if
this finale is like any other finale
we've ever had it's it's laced with
omage is to the cast to the writers to
the fans who've been there since the
very beginning it's beautiful it it's
funny it's bittersweet and yes there are
answers but it's all just kind of like
interwoven together to make this
beautiful gift for the fans when we do
find out ADEs identity will it be
because the girls have discovered who it
is or will ad reveal themselves to the
girls or to the audience I'm gonna say
that it's all kind of all of that at
once which is what makes it so brilliant
okay you know how bunch of things happen
at the same time the audience is seeing
it happen but like people are figuring
it out on their own while you're
watching it do I'm saying yeah you're
watching it happen is
audience and you're like oh she just
figured it out she just figured it out
they just figured it out this reveals
happening that's what's gonna happen is
it a moment one moment yeah absolutely
is Mona in the finale known as nothing
em are the fans gonna be happy I think
so I think it's a it's everything this
is gonna be the most emotional episode
we've ever had in so many reasons you're
gonna feel betrayed you're gonna feel
sad you're gonna feel happy it's just
gonna be it's everybody just bring
tissues okay just bring tissues if you
can drink have a have a glass of wine
because it's gonna be a journey there's
also a teaser out there where you have
all the dots on your face so it looks
like avatar iya had come into ammonia oh
yeah I think it would a Mona tar oh well
is it a Mona tar is it guitar yeah
Mona Berta well if it's a Mont are then
Mona would have to directly be talking
to ad which would be interesting so
you'll just have to wait because I mean
I'm not gonna confirm or deny what my
motion capture was for but I guess it
was motion capture have we and you put
dust on your face and then you have not
you have a favorite Mona episode Mona
moments I do have a favorite moan
episo-- it has not aired the episode
before the finale why is it why is it
your favorite
I feel like have me on after and we'll
discuss it will you come back I did like
I had some really fun scenes that I
really enjoyed playing with okay I will
come back yeah yeah it's a different
side of Mona that we haven't seen maybe
a little bit maybe a little bit yeah I
think I think she lets her guard down in
some way
then you you start to you start to learn
a little bit more about her and why she
is a she it love fantasy
[Music]